here now is Eric Trump executive vice
president of the Trump Organization Eric
I've got to say I've been in this town
for far too long
okay longer that I want to admit and
I've seen a lot of State of the Union
speeches this was phenomenal it really
was and it was a little long but you
know but it was it was okay that it was
long because so many things are going
well for America but the media's
takeaway has to be it was dark I don't
know what speech he was watching it was
incredible his uplifting he was
incredible I think my father won
re-election today I really mean that
I've seen every speech he's ever given
I've been to every State of the Union
he's ever been a part of Laura tonight
was his finest finest moment as
Americans we should be proud it was it
was just an incredible day for us a
incredible week for us when the
president is acquitted tomorrow this
will cap off a week where US MCA was
signed they started down the road toward
at least a conversation about Middle
East peace a plan you know it'll be you
know changed and worked on but of course
then this speech where we bring together
families who have been separated rush
limbaugh who whether you're a democrat
republican the man is a broadcasting
pioneer who's won every award you can
win in radio broadcasting multiple times
and encourage a generation of
broadcasters in the bitterness in the
meanness does that stem from there
knowing that right now at least it does
not look it looks dark for them they're
not losing it listen first of all they
had disastrous week coming out of Iowa
is just in Iowa the turnout for my
father in an uncontested election was
unbelievable we had hundreds and
hundreds of people showing up everywhere
we went in Trump's shirts and everything
else right they've had a disastrous week
he capped it off with the speech tonight
and they're upset they can't do Laura
they were talking about my father was
talking about you know the lowest
unemployment ever lowest female
unemployment the lowest african-american
wouldn't stand with that no they would
not stand for those moments do you see
the the suits all in white everyone's in
white the women every way that your
surrender white Jerry Nadler
sitting back slouching down pretending
to clap you know what it's disgusting
and you know what it turns off Americans
and men women like that women okay we
keep hearing about the gender gap with
your father
there's a big gender gap that's repeated
over and over again I think there is
something to overcome there I say to
women watching what happened tonight how
do you not take away from this that
something is wrong
deeply wrong in the Democrat Party you
might not like everything that Donald
Trump tweets or says but when you watch
the fact that Nancy Pelosi sits for
moments that are positive for women well
you know when she rips up a speech at
the end and when they're smug and when
they're angry and when they're nasty
especially and we have so much to be
proud of as a walking out Tim Tim Ryan
bill Pascrell Jackie Speier they walked
out of the speech that was their big
contribution to the conversation walking
out because they know they lost they
know they lost the sing tonight they
know their message isn't resonating they
know their party's a shamble they can't
throw on a basic caucus and I where they
can't count basic vote okay so yeah
let's go back to Iowa a whole bunch of
the radicals didn't show up I mean they
talk a good game but it was like
actually dude just show up be graceful
they didn't they had the nine of them
didn't show so you were there in Iowa
last night been traveling a lot as says
Don junior and everyone's on the road
tell us about what was happening there
the poor Democrats I mean they're still
unsure of what happens trickled in
slowly today well I think they're trying
to steal for Bernie because you know
it's almost clear that they've tried to
do that the entire time Biden had a
disastrous night and a true winner not
only could they not count their votes
the true winner was Trump because every
single place we went every caucus
location we went to had hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of people showing
up again my father's running uncontested
there's no need for anybody to show up
and everybody's coming in Trump hats and
make America great again gear and
they're bringing their children it was
unbelievable to the show of support was
absolutely I was like dan Patrick was
texting me at about 10 o'clock last
night he said I just left the precinct
we have record 30,000 people beat
Obama's number I almost felt well we're
not at 10:30 on Fox because our show was
was not on last night because the
coverage and it was like that tells you
something that's the statement people
want to make and
by the way I want to get a response to
what your dear friend congressman Eric's
wawel said before President Trump's
speech tonight we're not gonna stop
checking him because we've learned
through the impeachment process that we
show future presidents what the standard
of conduct is and there's been a lot of
continuing defamation of view your
brother your family that continues along
with promises of more impeachment
because we're winning in a slow low made
it exactly six weeks in the election
process remember he ran for president
exactly your god you just reminded you
got exactly zero percent of the vote so
it's kind of interesting you know so if
you can't win on your own
and your candidates are disasters and
you're doing horribly in Iowa and you
can't count basic votes and you have no
message and Trump delivers our great
state of the union speech guess what do
I make up something totally override the
democratic system in this country and
trying to pitch the guy you know what
they keep on crying wolf and it doesn't
get them anything and I'm telling you my
father is gonna win the greatest victory
in the history of American politics come
November because Americans see through
their nonsense I said in the angle that
the Democrats have to be punished by the
voters for what they've done
elevate the radicals investigation
impeachment mentality in the continuing
defamation of good people who are doing
their best do you think the voters are
going to punish the Democrats for what
they've done well they did in Iowa last
night and I think that's the first test
and I think you're gonna see that in
every single state my father has never
been more popular people are more
emboldened right now to come out and say
listen I'm behind this person he's done
an unbelievable job by every metric good
if he said did you see him tonight yeah
I was with him all night and the guy's
incredible I was so proud as a son
sentimentally honest I was so proud of
the man tonight he blew it out of the
water he did such a phenomenal job he
made our nation proud he made our family
proud it was his finest moment
it really was Eric thanks for coming in
I know you've had a very long and be
here 24 hours thanks so much for being
with